Raw milk. Shaken, not stirred.
Am I being detained? I'm filming you.
I have a right to film
you. I'm in a public place.
What is it?
Cutting edge nano technology.Smart blood.
Microchips in your bloodstream
allows us to track your
movements in the field.
I've come to the wrong queue.
Gay wedding cake shaken, not stirred.
Why does this bag of cocaine
have a CIA label on it?
Something we're making for the Americans,
it's called a ghetto blaster.
We definitely shouldn't do that.
And we probably shouldn't call it that.
Well, Mr. Bond,
soon, the United States
debt will top $29 trillion.
It's madness. Economic madness.
How did you pull off this heinous act?
Oh, I had nothing to do with
it. No, it was Congress.
Congress of the Soviet Union
tricked us into getting this debt.
What? No, the United States Congress.
Of America?.
Yes.
How much was it again?
$29 trillion.
Do we pay interest on that?
Yes.
All the time?
This is terrifying.
It's a great deal of money.
What do we do?
Honestly, it won't affect me very much
because I'm very wealthy.
Will I be okay?
Are you a federal employee?
Yes.
Then you'll be fine.
Oh, thank God.
What a waste
of perfectly good gold.
It's easily transferable. It's fungible.
Not difficult to assay. The
hedge against inflation.
It doesn't spoil. It's malleable.
We made it a microchip.
Sold coins and gold jewelry
And then Nixon took us
off the gold standard.
He's the true villain here.
You know, you're quite a good listener.
Usually people get bored
when I talk about gold.
You all right?
Two fingers of LSD. Shaken, not stirred.
Now pay attention, Bond.
An ordinary pen. inside is
a fraction of a drop of ink.
The rest is filled with a sense
of self-importance and the
desire to control the lives of others.
My God, it would take 10 of
these just to sign your name.
Ling, say goodbye to Felix. Man talk.
I was a different person back then.
I was literally a
different person back then.
You carry a double O number.
It means you're licensed
to kill, not get killed.
But I still need a license to braid hair?
Guess we're adding bagpipes to the list.
I'll have a bacon wrapped
hotdog. Shaken, not stirred.
I'll have a ginger ale and
Ayahuasca. Shaken, not stirred.
One infant.
Just hand it to me.
Oh, so it's like, seasteading, only evil.
Who are you?
My name is Pussy Galore.
Oh, right. What are your pronouns?
Pay attention bond. An
ordinary household printer.
However, if you press
this button right here,
$1 trillion enters the money supply.
Really? This button here?
This button right here.
Right there.
No harm in it, right?
Well, Mr. Bond, it's time I leave you.
I have a date with a rocket ship.
To blow up the moon?
Just to float about
for a bit as a tourist,
it sounds really fun.
Using hard-earned taxpayer dollars?
No I'm using my money.
Money you stole.
No. I provided goods and
services on the internet
during a pandemic.
I created a great amount
of value for many people
all across the globe.
I'm sorry, how is that evil?
I don't know. I just
said I was going to space
and everyone on Twitter got very angry.
Well, travel safe.
Thank you.
You're the first person to
actually wish me safe travels.
Everyone else just spray
painted my garage door.
You know, do you want to come with me?
Me?
Yes. I was going to bring mittens,
but now I'd rather bring you.
I would love to go to space.
Well let's go to space.
Let's go to space.
We have ice cream.
You're going to love it.
Shotgun.
I told you inflation was dangerous.
Vodka Martini. Shaken, to-go.